we are breastfeeding a seven week old
and may get the j j vaccine next week
are there any potential hazards we
should consider any benefit to waiting
one to two months before deciding on the
j j one
given that we are isolating and low risk
um so i'll just say just is this gonna
sound snarky but this is just a
long-standing
um slight linguistic irritation of mine
that um
except in extraordinarily rare
situations people don't collectively
breastfeed their baby
um and this started to become a thing
like in the 90s i think you know we're
pregnant no
you're not she's pregnant um we're
breastfeeding nope
she's breastfeeding well in this one
case
i see the look on your face but i'm
right on this one so in this case
there's a strong chance that uh they are
breast pumping which has its own set of
hazards associated with it but
it what would the term be if a couple is
using breast milk but both of them are
doing the feeding
yeah i think i would still say you know
bottle feeding from breast milk or
something just because breastfeeding is
the act the the behavioral interaction
as well but
you know it's it's a it's a minor thing
yeah and this question
is terrific and um and certainly the
person asking it doesn't deserve any
i'm not angry or upset just like
i'll bet only one of you is
breastfeeding um
any potential hazards uh to getting a j
j vaccine while breastfeeding uh a
practically a neonate seven weeks isn't
neonate but really really quite young
still
any benefit to waiting one to two months
um
given that you're isolating in low risk
i think so
i i think there's a benefit to to just
letting that kid get as much life behind
him or her as possible before before
exposing them
i can't remember actually what the
schedule of vaccines
for babies is it's been a long time
since ours were tiny but
um i don't think they vaccinate right
away do they don't they wait maybe six
weeks is actually the first vaccination
date and then mostly i don't remember
and um
so you know the expectations that
this um the effects of any vaccine that
mom gets can be passed through breast
milk and
i don't know for sure that's true here
but that's the expectation and so
especially if for instance the regular
vaccination schedule for baby doesn't
start until six months
um i would be real shy about um mom
who is breastfeeding getting any
vaccination not
not just one that happens to be brand
new with a
new technology while the baby is still
so young
yeah and that's just that's just caution
it's not based on data we don't have the
data
i i agree there is some evidence of
immunity
to ii being passed in breast milk
whether that could carry over from a
vaccine
and whether it even matters in this case
since kids seem to be
immune to it in the first place or very
close to immune to it
but you know the basic answer is
you're dealing with a novel intervention
in a complex system
you don't know what could be downstream
of that so
caution and therefore delaying things uh
is sensible and what you have to put
that up against is something
like the risk of
contracting of the parent contracting
sars cov2
right um in the interim i would say the
non-breastfeeding parent
should go ahead with the schedule you
know if it were if it were us
and we were scheduled and i had a seven
week old
baby at the breast um and we had decided
that now is the time
to get the j j vaccine um i would
i think that i would push for you to go
ahead and get it and me to wait as long
as we felt
safe and because that would help protect
us collectively
yes the important thing though is if the
decision was that it made sense to get
it
right if we had come to the conclusion
if we come to that conclusion and so
anyway we are not eligible yet so we
have not come to any definitive
conclusion but i would say you and i
both have
trepidations about all of these uh novel
at various different level vaccines
um and are at comparatively low risk
based on how much we're interacting with
other people
so uh it it unfortunately is a very
personal
decision but yes uh with a with a child
breastfeeding
um i would say there is extra extra risk
and a reason for caution especially if
you're in a safe situation